what's up mg cat hi all right look at
you in your crop top yeah yeah it's pink
your favorite color it is it is yeah
it's my daughter's favorite color i
think she probably inspired that at me
and then i'm like a fan of seeing an
empty space somewhere and like trying to
fill it and i feel like there was like
all of the
the palettes of the years prior to when
i started you know the pink guitar and
making everything pink around me like i
just needed a refresher you know so
pink is a vibrant color and you are
giving us all sorts of vibes with this
documentary but first off you're taking
on mgk is taking over msg tomorrow right
how are you feeling about
a blessing huh yeah yeah how do you
prepare for a show like that actually
it's this there's some odd like
synchronicity between me as a kid
watching jay-z's fade to black in the
madison square garden show and it's
selling out in the day and then ours
sold out in a day
and
even with fade to black because that was
uh
a documentary on a period in his life
just like it was you know a one or two
year span and that's the same with life
and pink and it's the same amount of
syllables and
it's kind of weird did you do that
knowingly
well i think we jokingly started calling
the doc fade to pink
and then my friend had a screensaver and
i had a french saying on it and i was
like what does that mean and it was like
oh it means life in pink and i was like
i've never seen anyone be able to
self-sabotage more than me
i'm like
the best self-sabotager i've ever
witnessed
well hopefully you didn't tattoo fade to
pink on your body
kind of like something else you tattooed
on your body and then you had to change
them
just saying just saying you put on in
full display your creativity your
vulnerability in this documentary you
even go into speaking about how you
almost took your own life while you're
on the phone with megan did i put the
shotgun in my mouth
and i'm
yelling on the phone and like the
barrels in my mouth
and i go to [__] the shotgun and the
bullet as it comes back up the shell
just gets jammed
megan's like dead silent
that was kind of where
i started realizing like
something's not
right
how have you healed from that experience
that you went through
that's like
something i'm not proud of it wasn't my
choice to have that in a documentary i
think that some of those things like
in in speaking on the truth for the last
two years
that is one of them and i didn't also
want to
hide anything so i gave everyone full
permission to put things in there
certain things didn't make it in there
which i'm glad they didn't but uh
i mean it's been an interesting two
years of
the
fame taking on a different
life than i could have imagined it doing
and then
me simultaneously
while that was skyrocketing i was trying
to level myself and ground myself and be
like make a choice to become a a better
father and a
a good partner to my to my lady and um
but we see the highs and the lows of
this period in your life which is
exceptional that you opened up to your
fans in in that means casey is such a
bright young lady
stole the doc to me yeah she she
i was i was talking with her about it
last night like she hasn't seen it yet
and um
and do you plan on watching it with her
i don't know man i don't know i don't
know i i don't know
i mean
to me she's so she speaks so eloquently
and she speaks so so truthfully and um i
think like the the torch will pass on to
her and she'll have her own
she'll have you know this is just the
start of her amazing lifestyle
i loved hearing you say that it was all
about the legacy you live in leaving her
you know
it's a beautiful thing because she'll be
better than i am
you know like she'll she'll she'll learn
from these things that i'm going through
and then hopefully you know i can see it
in her already she's better than i am
and she'll be better than i could ever
be well you seem to be making a valiant
effort on that part for sure now i got
to say i did hear you say in the
documentary you call megan the son mgk
you also call her your wife yeah yeah
yeah
your wife so when's the anniversary when
did that happen
oh i mean i think you know when i speak
on uh
if we're talking about terminology
with the connection that her and i have
it never felt right calling on my
girlfriend
so you've always referred to as your
wife well i mean
i refer to as many things but never as
a girlfriend seems too adolescent for
the
like the depth of our relationship so
yeah yeah
it's beautiful to see you two together
what impact have your two ladies
casey and megan both how they impacted
your life for the better i think all the
women in my life you know even my
manager she's she's a woman she's the
one who dropped out of college and
believed in me and took me into her
house and um
you know the maybe that's why paint
gravitated to me
so
early on in my life
because well because it's funny i
watched this video of me as a kid
and my mom got me a pink boxing bag
and my dad was like why would you get
him a pink boxing bag
my gosh how precious are you to thank
you are you so proud of this young man
right here i am i'm super proud it's
crazy that he has a documentary he's
only 32. i know he looks 11.
he's got a lot of life left to live and
you guys have been living a lot of life
here recently together that's an
understatement i mean
and we are all here to spectate that's
for sure but um and you've made a
valiant effort in going out on tour with
them and being out on the road why is it
important for you to get out there and
support
coulson here um well it's just hard to
be away from
someone that you love and
i think it's important to maintain
intimacy in a relationship in the
distance it's very even with facetimes
or things like that it's it's difficult
to maintain a really deep level of
engagement with a partner and so i try
to be there as much as i can i won't be
able to be on the whole tour but
i try to be present yeah as much as
possible i do believe you told me at the
vmas what daddy wants daddy
he was like you're gonna be naked
tonight and i was like whatever you say
daddy whatever daddy says it was like
the most memorable line i do believe
i've ever received in an interview
before thank you i'm good for those i'm
good for those sound bites oh my gosh um
now golsan here refers to you as the son
his wife how do you refer to him
oh he's got all the names yeah yeah he
has lots of nicknames well obviously
daddy we know daddy's one of them for
sure
but i'm curious do you guys have an
official anniversary for the wedding day
no we don't know what's happening we
both are very tight-lipped about we just
honestly don't know yet like he's on
tour this year so we're just playing it
by ear and then when it when it needs to
happen it'll open up the universe will
open it up and we'll do it i love it
fantastic and finally um coulson
displays i mean he shows such
vulnerability in this documentary and he
went through a very difficult time when
he considered taking his own life you
were on the receiving end of that phone
call while he was having those feelings
how have you helped them through that
difficult time and how the two of you
healed and grown together um we've done
every form of therapy that exists
we've found a therapist that really
works for us couples and individually
and it's definitely a process it's not
an easy one
some of some of it's really difficult
but
our therapist said that a relationship
is basically the process of breaking
each other down but most people don't
have the tools to build each other back
up to rebuild and so it's a constant
process of like suffering
and passion and love and the repeat
cycle so we're just
learning that and navigating that and
doing that together and there's lots of
all of those things all of the time
[Music]